let's go inside I don't know what to do
I think you've broken me this is the end
[Music]
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis a chef who's always up for a
challenge we've taken to you Internet to
ask what weird appliance I should make a
three-course meal with and I'm so
excited to see what I've got next ready
three two one
this is a joke I'm speechless there's a
there's two sauce there's a drill a heat
gun and a hammer this is really
upsetting yeah I don't know what I can
do I need some time I know you can use a
saw to cut meat that's what butchers do
that doesn't feel crazy there's a
blender people make sauces it looks like
the heat gun has quite a bit of heat
they can get like up to a thousand
degrees which is pretty cool I mean
that's hotter than most ovens so I'm not
feeling confident right now listen the
silver lining is that it seems like when
I have unusual tools sometimes things go
better than when I have real kitchen
appliances if that can happen today that
would be fantastic okay I've got a plan
let's see if it works it's gonna be you
know rustic homey we'll see I'm gonna
have Ryan go to the store well I got
everything ready here Ryan your first
course I'm going to make a charred
little gem Caesar salad with some crispy
prosciutto I'm gonna start easy by
making the dressing I've had a safety
training so I feel fairly comfortable
with all these tools please do not try
this at home this is not for home use
usually I would make a paste from garlic
and anchovies but I can't do that with a
sauce so I'm gonna smash it with a
hammer that was a vision got some
anchovies here I know they're fairly
polarizing but I would honestly eat this
whole jar they're so good
this is maybe even more efficient than a
knife I'm not gonna lie this is weird
it's a beautiful paste this is exactly
how it should look I'm gonna go wash my
hands and wash this hammer off okay
moving on I'm gonna prep my lemon with
my saw I've been given this very handy
attachment for the drill maybe the other
way
oh I reverse it cool hey that's an arm
into the anchovy paste you're gonna add
a little mustard there we go beautiful a
little pinch of salt
and I'm gonna add two egg yolks
the easiest way to get egg yolks out is
to crack them into a bowl and just use
your hands to really delicately go back
and forth and get it out like that so
I've got a lender attachment so far so
good I mean this is this is pretty much
what I would do at home I mean I
wouldn't do this at home but I would get
it to this stage it looks great I'm
going to add the olive oil to make an
emulsion and actually this makes it even
easier than if I was like using a hand
whisk because I can actually just
drizzle it in my drop by drop until it
forms my lemon I can't use a juicer
today so just just squeeze it in give it
a taste
mmm that is pretty damn good I'm gonna
have Ryan put this in the fridge and
then I'm gonna move on to the rest of
the salad I'm going to make some crispy
prosciutto with a heat gun so the heat
guns get really hot so you want to
always do it well you actually don't
want to do this at home ever I want to
do this on a metal tray so that it
doesn't burn and again we're going
rustic so just a few torn pieces of
prosciutto
no everyone kept warning me that this
was gonna be super hot but it's not
feeling that way yet so maybe it takes a
minute to like get crazy Wow okay it's
happening it's happening it's pretty
cool it the fat from the prosciutto like
immediately seizes up and kind of melts
away it's like not the most efficient
with putting works I'm actually really
happy with the prosciutto it's like
beautiful crispy bits I think I can move
on to the next part I am gonna make
croutons and I'm gonna solve this
Bredesen squishy that the saw is not
doing much you know I'm gonna use my
hands to just tear it up sometimes
there's no better tool than your hands
these can actually go on here because
I'm gonna drizzle the croutons with
olive oil and then use this heat them to
make them like a little Christmas
it smells like we're in a bakery this is
great hmm the olive oil makes it taste
more like a crouton where otherwise of
just tastes kind of like toast
croutons took a little bit of time so
far the most time-consuming thing but
honestly they look beautiful I'm gonna
move on to my greens I'm gonna use the
saw again so pretty maybe I want to
quarter it beautiful I'm actually so
excited about this the salad is one of
my dinner party staples and I feel like
it's coming together in a really
beautiful way confidence level is like
you know things could change but salad
Ted I'm gonna just drizzle these with
some oil and I'm just gonna get them
lightly charred I think having the char
just adds a little more texture and some
smoky flavor okay I'm gonna move on to
my next course skipping ahead and gonna
do my full dessert course for dessert
I'm going to make brûléed pineapple with
a dollop of whipped cream and shaved
chocolate and I'm thrilled to report I'm
gonna start with the whipped cream and
for once I have a beater all I have
asked for since I started the show is to
have a beater I always have to do this
by hand and it takes like 20 minutes and
I'm exhausted
I wish has been answered here we go
you know here's the thing I've only got
one [ __ ] not two and it's not gonna
take some time but I think way better
than doing it by hand I take back what I
said doing this my hand would be easier
this has been like 20 minutes and it's
like soupy still we're gonna add a
little sugar one day I will measure
something for us it works it's just not
efficient I think this is as good as
it's gonna get I'm not gonna get stiff
peaks which is fine but more of a like
loosey-goosey swoopy time for some fun
stuff start with chocolate it's got a
little salt this is kind of like a knife
that feels easy I'm just gonna this is
great
I just want to sprinkle this over top so
I don't need that much okay the
pineapple from the soul I would assume
that this actually could be very smart
because pineapples are a pain to cut and
I don't know cool I think this big blade
is like pretty helpful it feels weird
and it feels different but that's not a
bad thing okay I want this cord I don't
have a knife but I have this little saw
so I think I can just go my confidence
level yes 7 ok pineapple rings like
something I'm gonna just put some sugar
over the pineapple torch it and it
should get caramelized and kind of
hardened and beautiful but let's see
some of the sugar crystals are
dissolving okay the sugar is starting to
bubble you know it looks like it's
starting to caramelize but it's taking a
really long time the heat gun does work
but it's not super efficient oh my god
okay one pineapple has taken about 20
minutes and it looks beautiful it smells
amazing that smells like deeply
intensely caramelized and like fruity
and sweet but this is crazy I'm gonna do
one more and call it a day you know I'm
not gonna spend my day just heating up
pineapple I've been with these two
pineapple slices for about 45 minutes
now so I'm gonna move on last thing I
have to do taking the pineapple away I'm
going to make a raw fennel celery and
apple slaw a bit of mustard a bit of
mayo and scallops which I'm not sure how
it's gonna turn out but everything's
worked so far so just got to hope for
the best I am gonna start with the
fennel and this time I'm gonna use my
little babies law my little baby saw for
my slaw there we go
okay taking off these Timbs I'm gonna
save these because I think it'd be nice
to toss some of the fennel fronds into
the slaw okay my little saw isn't quite
big enough so move on to the big one
it's a rough cut let me tell you like
this is not a pretty smooth knife
situation oh maybe this saw I'm trying
to cut out the core of the fennel which
is really hard and generally don't want
to eat it slow work I keep saying with
all these episodes like give me heat
blah blah blah and I'm taking for
granted like a knife it's really making
me appreciate the most basic of tools oh
god I think that's enough I think I'm
gonna move on to the celery nice Wow it
is a rough situation
I'm also destroying this cutting board
I'm so sorry I mean the celery is much
easier than the fennel it's just because
of the size
and the texture okay done with a celery
that's plenty now the Apple I'm using
granny smith apples which are bright and
crunchy you know I haven't made the slaw
but it's a pretty classic combination
okay this is actually fairly efficient
okay
it feels dangerous actually Alameda I'm
gonna take the anchovy over an apple any
day
got my sloth it looks really rough it
looks like a child cut it I'm gonna make
my dressing I've got some Kewpie
mayonnaise which is type of Japanese
mayonnaise made with egg yolks and rice
vinegar so it's got more of a tangy rich
flavor and some whole-grain mustard oh
no I have to get the lemon this is cool
adding a little pepper a little bit of
salt
mixing it again okay I think I need more
mayonnaise it's a bit too tangy I want
it to be a little creamier you know the
secret to being a good cook is tasting
along the way so if you're tasting along
the way you can make fixes like this so
I'm just gonna add the whole thing and
I'm just gonna use my hands to toss cool
okay I'm gonna throw this in the fridge
and then the scallops okay the last
thing I have to do is to sear some
scallops with a heat gun I thought that
I could oil this tray and then kind of
heat it up a bit with the heat gun add
the scallop heat the top also gonna
season it I'm gonna do a quick season
it's just salt pepper pretty okay we got
a bunch of trays it's really safe
this is oiled I think that'll work and
I'm just gonna heat it if I was searing
scallops at home on a stovetop I would
do it over high heat for like a minute
or two on each side they go really fast
and you want scallops to be like just
barely cooked through and you really
don't want them to get tough so I
thought the heat gun my
a similar principle it's getting pretty
hot so
Oh should I all top maybe
it's giving
you know the scallop has gone from being
kind of translucent to opaque which is
what what I want oh I don't even have a
butter knife Jesus I'm gonna saw a
scallop mmm it's delicious that is like
the coolest thing I've ever done the
pepper gets kind of I don't have burnt
but more fragrant and aromatic which is
kind of nice it's like a warm peppery
thing from the heat it's funny I thought
the pineapple was gonna be the easiest
thing I thought just you know brilliant
there's no problem but it turns out
scallops MVP baby I'm gonna get this all
plated up and then it's time for my
taste tester
this is my friend to tell me oh she was
also the taste tester on last season's
finale so I'm extra excited tougher back
because I think things got a little
weirder this time Oh later I mean this
time you knew we were like in the woods
you knew what was happening okay I I'm
excited cuz I really don't know okay are
you ready for the first course yeah I'm
gonna for our first course we have a
charred little gem Caesar with some
croutons and some crispy prosciutto oh I
like it
should I get like a little bit of
everything you can you can have one bet
you can have many bites you know to do
what you think mmm this dressing is
really good thank you
there's like so many elements it's like
nice and crispy nice and charred nice
and toasty this is a winner
thank you okay let me get the second
dish we've got a fennel apple celery
slaw some whole grain mustard some
fennel fronds and then some scallops
okay and this is so fancy what do you
think about the cook on the scallops
besides perfect I mean I love is there
char thing happening here I don't know
is there a shower thing happening in
there it kind of is the salad is also
very refreshing which goes with the
seafood it's delicious thank you okay
we've got one more mm-hmm dessert mmm
there's a little abstract air brulee
pineapple with some whipped cream and
chocolate shavings
this is my favorite thing to do when I
go camping I love that's a pineapple oh
my god that's amazing
no good I'm actually Wow hmm he's like a
crunch there's a real crunch like a
creme brulee yeah okay I think I know
well you think you know I think so okay
what do you think
my guess is liturgy you're close but
you're not right for this meal I was
given only hand tools
what like these huh how'd you do that
and this oh and a heat gun oh that's
right but this one I had a fancy little
blender yeah yeah yeah yeah and then I
didn't have any knives I only had saws
oh we're going is that you're about to
make the dressing you would have never
guessed yeah cuz I I had a total panic
when I first saw it I was like there's
no way but there's a way well thank you
very much yeah well I learned something
new and I'm gonna finish this okay
you guys I did it I had such an amazing
time it's been such a wild ride let me
know if you've used any of these tools
to make something fun in the comments
see you soon
[Music]